what are some tips on long lasting love
that's a good one
uh Bobby yeah Bobby I can't wait to hear
this
oh I I would say that
um
you know Scott Peck wrote This Book
the rug Less Traveled the first
a line of that book is that love is
effort
and you know to understand that love is
not that kind of adolescent infatuation
that's a wonderful feeling and it should
be part of every relationship but you
know the the
um the important part of
of love is to uh is recognizing that it
means you know
um making the effort of of you know I
try to
anticipate what Cheryl wants and what's
going to make her happy and I try to do
that I don't like washing the dishes but
I enjoy doing them because I know it's
going to make her happy
I had a um this guy told me one time
when I first
sorry when I first got started drifting
away from the microphone I'm like good
back he told me he told me the story
that he was staying up on night with a
baby which I knew that feeling well you
know how exhausting it is and how
demanding it is when you have you know
when you have young children that they
just keep you up all night and
I he was letting his wife sleep and he
was said the baby was sick the child was
sick it was uh you know maybe three or
two or three year old
and that he was sitting up because the
child had group or something that you
know was regularly getting them up
during the night he was sitting in a
chair in the in an easy chair it's sort
of dozing in the child's room
and the baby cried and he jumped up but
he literally leaped up and when he
landed he planted his foot on a um the
heel of his foot on a thumbtack which
buried itself in his heel
and he said that his first feeling at
that point was that of extraordinary
gratitude that he had landed on that
Thumbtack rather than the child finding
it oh and uh
you know to me that was kind of one of
the first times I started thinking about
what love really is which is not you
know just which is not something that is
ego driven or
self-serving but something that is
completely willing to put all of your
ego and self-will inside and to you know
to try to really
um do you know live
to make the other person happy wow
that was beautiful that was sweet
you hear that
yeah I [__] up dishes I [__] it up
dishes yeah yeah I didn't do any of that
yeah yeah I didn't put no I put no
effort in it I'm sorry I [__] up all
right that's why you guys are where you
are yeah but in the next life yeah
you'll see upper yeah well you'll see
the next girl is gonna Live It Up listen
listen guys I was petrified about this
product I really was because you know
we've had just silly people on you know
what I mean but you guys were so silly
you guys were so fun and um I just like
you guys so much man I really do I I
really like you dude Bobby you're cool
cool dude and hopefully you know because
you know I'm friends with buying